writing a book helps you meet more
people but it also gives you an
opportunity to interview amazing people
you don't have to be super smart or
super talented people with less talent
and less wisdom and less expertise than
you have gotten their book to Market I
think it just takes a commitment it
takes making a decision and then there
are some helpful tools and we'll share
those with you in a second
welcome back to the think media podcast
we're talking all about reasons to write
a book as a YouTube content creator or
digital entrepreneur and how to finally
make it happen this is part two of a
two-part Series so I highly recommend
checking out wherever you consume the
podcast in our archives in the Library
part one we covered five reasons why
every YouTube Creator should write a
book and we are talking about a little
bit of the lessons I've learned writing
YouTube secrets with my friend Benji
that's now on the second edition over a
hundred thousand copies sold over 3122
reviews over three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars generated just from
self-publishing a book and millions of
dollars of revenue generated because of
the brand lift and the awareness and the
benefits of packaging what you know into
a book I would argue for those that are
objecting but who reads books anymore
well clearly a hundred thousand people
who you would think
well they're watching YouTube they're on
the internet nobody's reading books if
any book proves that people are still
reading books it's YouTube secrets
because we're talking about digital and
social media and so this isn't even one
of the reasons but I think one of the
reasons actually to why every YouTube
Creator should write a book is because
you're going to tap into a market that
reads books and you're going to expand
your brand wider than you could ever
imagine
and so more people are reading books
than ever by the way there's book talk
on Tick Tock and Barnes Noble is
actually opening stores and so some
people are like books are on the way out
it's not true and some of the reasons
are going to clarify even more about the
power books that's where these lessons
are coming from and so we're going to
get into seven lessons in this episode
and check out part one for the others
but number six technically and I'm gonna
go one through seven in my number ring
but it's out of a total of 12. so number
one it gives you more influence and
credibility so writing a book gives you
more influence and credibility you'll be
seen as a thought leader or an expert
it'll accelerate know like and Trust
now if you want people to ever do
business with you or buy your stuff you
need people to first know you we learned
in the last episode that Amazon is a
search engine you could actually get
discovered by essentially cold traffic
meaning people don't just buy your book
because they discovered your YouTube
channel they can discover just your book
on Amazon if it's positioned well if
it's clear if you make it about the
right topic you have a few positive
reviews
people just buy your book and that's the
way they meet you well they get to know
you now if they already know you though
but they you want them to get to know
you man raping a book is no greater it's
the deepest way I think of growing and
getting to know somebody
listening to an audiobook my gosh
someone spends three four five hours
with you listening to audio man talk
about the depth of someone getting to
know you then it's their choice to
determine if they like you or not and
that's going to be key because then
eventually they trust you so they can do
business with you and what's interesting
about also just getting more influence
and credibility though is even
if people don't read the book this is a
dirty secret of writing books
even if people don't
read the book
you'll have more influence and
credibility
I my I predict and I guess that there is
books on your shelf
that you haven't read
I'm guessing even if you are a fan of
think media that you might have
purchased YouTube secrets
but you didn't read it is that true am I
calling anyone out
but let me ask you
especially if you listen to the think
media podcast on YouTube did you think I
had any more influence and credibility
simply because of the book even if you
didn't read it did you think oh yeah I
mean then it's a book I read the first
chapter I yeah I mean it was just so I
think we all understand that
as hard as it is like hopefully people
read it but even if they don't
it'll give you more influence and
credibility
and influence and credibility in today's
world can be Tran translated
into
profitability
into more income for you and your
business number seven
number two sorry so I mean we're going
through the seven points
how should I number them we're in the
podcast together number two gives you
the opportunity to clarify your unique
way of doing things
so
this
is
powerful for educational channels
coaches if you ever want to create an
online course if you ever want to bring
about some kind of transformation in
people's lives
there's two concepts I want you if
you've never heard about these before I
want to encourage you to consider
Frameworks in a proprietary process
so
for anybody who's teaching something on
YouTube
you're going to be a hundred times
stronger if you've created a framework
than somebody who has not
what does that mean a framework is a
repeatable process
that people can follow that is clear
hopefully simple
and
my examples of Frameworks are the seven
C's of YouTube success those are that's
the framework inside of the book it's
part one of YouTube secrets
we have the seven R's that's inside of
video ranking Academy in one sense at
think media YouTube Secrets seven C's of
YouTube success is kind of
like how to get started it's kind of a
beginner framework getting you from just
no YouTube channel to started
and then VRA while many people also
start with VRA it is more advanced it
goes really deep so technically there's
two Frameworks in our business as of
right now there's the seven C's and the
7rs
um the punch line is though if you study
great business books great personal
development books
historically great
um transformational books they have
Frameworks so Seven Habits of Highly
Effective People there's like a
framework you can Google it and look it
up
the advantage by Patrick lancione
there's a framework I was reading a book
about like missionary work for churches
and there was like a framework of how to
reach a city
so great leaders build Frameworks and
that's an episode for its on its own but
this gives you the opportunity to
clarify your unique way of doing things
into a framework now the second term is
a proprietary process what's powerful
about that
is the word proprietary your unique way
of doing things so nobody else has the
seven C's of YouTube success nobody else
has the seminars
and so this becomes a thought leadership
where where somebody else is like I have
a list of things for you to do okay
think about that compared to a
proprietary process
somebody else says I don't know I kind
of just gathered some chapters together
put them in a book compare that to an
unbreakable framework
and so this lets you create your own
system or your own way of doing things
and what's very cool about it and let me
know if whether you want to leave a
review on Apple that's where I could
hear from you there or especially on
YouTube if you would ever like deeper
trainings on this I could cover this in
future episodes because I want to keep
it moving but
one of the cool things about creating a
framework is I could extemporaneously
meaning I could go
speak on stage about the seven C's
and
with no notes
walk through a process of starting a
YouTube channel
because back to episode one it forced me
to learn my material more organize my
thoughts and the seven C's of YouTube
success is a repeatable process
now here's what I want to encourage you
it was not easy to do this but now that
I've done this I'm so grateful that I've
got this repeatable process and same
thing with the 7rs
give me a white board and a pen
give me a podcast and I could walk
through what they are what they mean
and then you know if you join our video
ranking Academy program
you could see that the 7rs are 55 hours
of content as well so the cool thing
about a framework is you could list it
off go around the cycle at a 101 level
201 level 301 level 401 level
you create a framework you could teach
it in one hour you could teach it
actually in five minutes one hour half a
day one day a three-day Workshop because
there's different levels of depth to it
but as kind of a separate note for just
knowledge workers and high levels of
thought leadership in general Frameworks
and proprietary processes are not
essential to writing a book but this
gives you the opportunity to lean into
that and Anna as a result on the other
side you will powerfully position
yourself your knowledge in your way of
doing things to transform more lives to
be easier to understand
and to help your book and your overall
business in the process and so in this
episode we're going through seven more
things I'm just going to list one
through seven the first five are in
first episode so number one it gives you
more influence and credibility number
two gives you the opportunity to clarify
your unique way of doing things number
three you can reach more people with an
audiobook I would argue that one of the
main reasons to write a book this year
is just for the audiobook
I think that some of these points could
just stand alone but I think the audio
book is such a powerful tool
that if that's all
you did or that's the only thing that
really made an impact it would be worth
doing all the other work
because
writing down the words or capturing them
and letting AI synthesize them or
whatever because a lot of cool things
you could do but once you have that
final manuscript
your voice
on the microphone on Audible on people's
phones better than a podcast because
it's more organized
it's been refined it's been tweaked it's
been polished and it can provide an
experience it could provide
transformation it could provide impact
to The Listener in an intimate way just
like podcasts are intimate
I put a lot of effort into these but
nowhere near as much polish as an
audiobook and if you've ever listened to
the YouTube Secrets audiobook
we paid for
a professional studio very good
investment but if you just had your USB
mic in a setup like I'm on right now
also very possible to create an
audiobook and now
you're impacting people at a whole
nother level
and you can get once you have a book one
of the cool things you can do as another
way of making money is say hey do you
want my book for free
just go to
Audible
sign up for an account and use your free
credit for my book you get a commission
I think it's five dollars or ten dollars
depending on like what happens next just
for people signing up for a trial even
if they don't stick with it
so if you go to tube secretsaudio.com
and you don't have Audible I can promote
that I'll say hey go to tube
secretsaudio.com grab my book for free
now if somebody already has audible they
can go use a credit for it or purchase
it and net net that's why we made fifty
thousand dollars so far from Audible
whatever it's called in the back end
like ACX or something
and
again though more than the money
is the intimacy and I think audiobooks
are the most practical way of consuming
books for most people
so you might not you might be like I
don't read books but I listen to
audiobooks so getting the work done of
writing your book is to get your book on
audio so now you can go on road trips
with people right you can do chores with
people and
following especially like great
promotion principles and having getting
help and getting mentorship and writing
your book
audible can be its own platform of
Discovery separate from Amazon it's a
place of getting discovered ranked and
recommended
just like the YouTube algorithm think
about people who listen to this also
listen to this like you want to be in
that suggested section
of audiobooks
of books and so going through the whole
process of not just writing a book and
getting it out on physical and ebook but
also audiobook man that's one of the
reasons why every YouTube Creator should
write a book
and it's
easier than it's ever been before
number four this allows you to make a
positive impact on others
you get to share your wisdom and your
expertise with more people when you
write a book number five leave a lasting
Legacy for future Generations they do
say I think they surveyed Americans and
like almost everybody wants to write a
book not everybody wants to write a
business book of course but think about
the opportunity
of your lessons your wisdom your
expertise your mistakes your stories
just being put into a book
for many that is enough motivation to
want to
do what it takes to get the book out and
I think that Legacy similar to why we
want to help you grow on YouTube
build a channel you're proud of make
money go full time one of the reasons to
create YouTube content depending on the
content you're creating
is Legacy history capturing like I would
love
you know my grandfather low Reed has
passed away and we got to have some fond
memories together but I think back now
and I'm like man if I could have seen
videos of him sharing his wisdom lessons
he's learned in his life
capturing some of those things or just
any kind of content just seeing and
remembering that and so we're living in
a
an incredible era where we can create
history and Legacy on YouTube the same
is true
writing a book
if it can help you leave a lasting
Legacy for future generation number six
it helps you expand your network of
contacts writing a book helps you meet
more people opens more doors but it also
gives you an opportunity to interview
amazing people
not everyone's book will include that
but one of the things we did for video
influencers
which was our YouTube channel at the
time and then the book YouTube Secrets
was we interviewed by the time the book
was out first edition we had interviewed
over 100 people second edition we
interviewed over 200 people
now think about compounding all the
lessons we've learned
I grew because of those interviews I
learned more things because of those
interviews I became a better Creator
because of those interviews I have
a network of creators in my phone and
cell phone numbers not like everybody
gave me their cell phone numbers but
like I've made friends and run into
people multiple years
you know in a row and built
relationships because of those
interviews
and
you might have a YouTube channel or a
podcast which is a great place to do
those because why not conduct those
interviews in public but sometimes
people do them hey I'm writing a book
would you be open to
an interview
and that can expand your network of
contacts
think about how valuable that is in
terms of what it is you want to build
over the next one two three four years
and then number seven and finally and
I'm going to re recap all 12 points
there was five in the first one seven in
the second one 12 total and we'll get
all the numbers in a row in just a
second
but the final point is it's now easier
and more affordable than ever before and
so the cool thing is you can write a
book I think it's accepting the fact you
can do this
it is something that's possible for you
um you don't have to be super smart or
super talented people with less talent
and less wisdom and less expertise than
you have gotten their book to Market I
think it just takes a commitment it
takes having uh making a decision and
then there are some helpful tools and
we'll share those with you in a second
but
um I want to encourage you that it's
easier than and more affordable than
ever before close to free
I think it's it's smart though to think
about
yes you could pay someone to help you
format it and there's could be fees
related to that yes it's smart to you
know get a good cover and good
um there's you know we've all seen books
that are formatted like DIY compared to
like proper formatting and so while
what's cool is you can do it like I did
get get noticed out by yourself that was
my first book my little ebook we talked
about in episode one terrible but it
came out cover ebook Amazon uploaded it
like a word doc
it was pretty janky but at least it was
a step forward
YouTube for churches my second book much
better I bought some software I paid for
some education and some coaching
I think I paid in a gift card Rachel
Sneed from our church who helped me edit
so at least I had somebody who knew how
to spell and edit
I uh went over and over and over again
it still had mistakes but it was pretty
good it was pretty polished I myself was
a designer so I designed the cover but
if you're not a designer yeah you should
probably get help you know there is AI
and things these days but you should
probably have you know it could be very
affordable to think about the cover of
course as you think about the book
getting the layout cover spine back
cover you know interior sections like it
can be kind of overwhelmed that's
actually why
the smartest move if you're serious is
to connect with somebody who can just
streamline the entire process and you
know my that's what my friend Chandler
bolt does at self-publishing school and
there's a uh a class that we're
co-hosting with him at
startyourbook.live and I'll tell you a
little bit more about that in a second
but ultimately it's easier and more
affordable than ever before so the key
is making the decision to do it and
stick with it and as a result I really
believe you can experience these 12
things and here's the recap so I believe
everybody should write
a book
that's a YouTube Creator a knowledge
worker that desires to build a personal
brand be a thought leader because number
one it helps you organize your thoughts
better number two it helps you learn and
grow number three it's a great way to
earn money number four it opens up more
chances for Success number five it makes
your personal brand stronger number six
it gives you more influence and
credibility number seven it gives you
the opportunity to clarify your unique
way of doing things
number eight you can reach more people
with an audiobook
number nine it allows you to make a
positive impact on others number ten
it leaves the lasting Legacy for future
Generations
number 11 it helps you expand your
network of contacts and number 12 it's
now easier and more affordable than ever
before
and in this two-part series you can
listen for expanded thoughts on the
first five points as well as a little
bit more of the backstory and details
of the four books essentially that I've
written
but of course on the think media podcast
we always introduce you to The Experts
who are true Specialists when it comes
two things that are outside of our
domain you subscribe here because it's
YouTube you want to start grow monetize
a YouTube channel learn about all things
video video marketing then definitely be
subscribed to the think media podcast
but if after all this you would say
I want to think about writing a book see
how that could be possible for you and
see how you could finally make it happen
with the help of Chandler's information
he's hosting a free class we're going to
be hosting it together
you can register at startyourbook.live
not.com it's startyourbook.live and it's
all about how to write and publish your
book and how to add six figures in
Revenue to your business this year by
publishing a book
using a book to double your lead sales
and referrals how to guarantee your book
will actually make money from day one
there's a particular way you want to set
it up how to write your book in a
weekend without even writing a single
word
I believe that's some new stuff I've
done this with Chandler before but I I
can't wait to learn from Chandler
because hey I'm going to write more
books
after YouTube secret second edition
uh B the game is changing so that's why
I follow Chandler because there's new
tools there's faster tools there's ways
like what's really cool about technology
AI YouTube software
is yes things like competition arising
but also
tools that help you go faster coaching
and mentors that streamline the process
and those who invest in the best mentors
and the best tools and the best coaching
and the best information are gonna have
the advantage and so it is pretty wild
and so I'm gonna be taking notes Just
Like You on the class on how to write a
book in a weekend without writing a
single word how to successfully launch
your book and create a six-figure book
funnel and so much more Chandler I
believe is giving away a copy of his
book published for free just for
attending the class and then of course
he's got you know products and services
as he will let you know about if you
want to go to the next level but whether
those are right for you or not
this free class will 100 be worth your
time if you would say
Sean I see that I do want to write a
book I see the benefits I think it's
something I want to tackle then just go
to startyourbook dot live there's a link
in the show notes as well to check that
out this is the think media podcast and
if you benefit from this show it would
mean the world to me if you shared it
with somebody is there somebody in your
life that's thinking about starting or
growing a YouTube channel
somebody who the subject matter of this
episode would resonate with them
would you consider hitting that little
share button grabbing the URL or the
share link using your mobile device from
a podcast audio listening Place shooting
them a text and being like hey this was
some fire content check this out that
mean the world to me and then if you can
rate and review the podcast wherever you
consume it that would be incredible as
well we've got some powerful episodes
coming up soon and so I want to thank
you for being a part of our community
sending you massive love and respect
today and uh absolutely committed to
helping you grow on YouTube
but also helping you develop Mastery in
your subject matter because especially
on YouTube content is king So you're
going to make your content stronger
than ultimately organizing your thoughts
better creating better content becoming
an even deeper subject matter expert
yourself
we're committed here at the think media
podcast to continuing to hopefully iron
sharpens iron helping you level up and
helping you get results with YouTube and
in your business overall so definitely
subscribe if you're not subscribed and I
can't wait to see you in the next
episode
take care